humankind loves to build walls have you
ever noticed that we built walls for
everything for shelter for protection
for privacy over the past seventy years
the number of barriers between countries
has doubled right now there are more
walls than at the end of the Second
World War
more than during the Cold War growing up
in Germany the fall of the Berlin Wall
always felt to me like the introduction
of a new world a world without barriers
but since the attacks of 9/11 the
construction has experienced an extreme
rise since then the amount has doubled
with about 30 new structures that were
planned or built walls and fences are
often built with the intention of
security security from another group of
people from crime from illegal trades
but walls and fences only provide us
with a feeling of security which is
different from real security even though
they might make us feel safe the
structures themselves can't protect us
instead they do something else they
separate they create on us and at them
they establish an enemy walls make us
build a second wall in our head a mental
wall and those mental walls slowly make
us lose sight of all the things we have
in common with the people on the other
side the other way around
mental walls can grow so strong that
they encourage us to build keep or
strengthen physical walls physical and
mental walls are closely interlinked and
one almost always comes with the other
it's a constant cycle physical walls
empower mental walls and mental walls
empower physical walls until at one
point one part falls away and the cycle
is disrupted when the Berlin Wall was
being built it was hard to tell who the
was facing because the people living
around it identified as one there was no
us and them there was no others
during the time of separation both sides
developed differently and formed
individual identities all of a sudden
that wasn't us and at them a mental wall
was built and when the Berlin Wall fell
again in 1989 this mental wall in the
head of the people state eastern Germans
had to be reintegrated into their own
country and even though they didn't have
to move places many still today feel
like they have never fully arrived those
remaining effects of the mental wall are
also measurable a study from the fly'
University of Berlin in 2005 shows that
even 15 years after the reunification
Germans still believe that cities on the
other side of the former wall a further
away than they really are the
interesting thing is that they found a
link between political attitude and
estimation of the distance the more a
participant was against the German
reunification the further away the
estimated cities to be it's the mental
wall which keeps cities on the other
side far away and the higher and
stronger this mental wall the more
difficult they seem to be reached I
tried to repeat the study with a group
of young Germans who grew up without the
wall to see if these effects are still
measurable nowadays and the results show
that this generation my generation is
just kind of bad at geography in general
east and west
but in our defense this could be seen as
an improvement right we never
experienced the actual wall this
physical barrier was never able to make
us build a mental wall in the first
place I would love to take this as a
serious indication that there could be a
future without a mental wall dividing
Germany but I think we have to face
reality this one wall could be
disappearing but in the meanwhile a
billion others are constructed one
global trend we are currently experience
thing is the rise of gated communities
and in a way gated communities can be
seen the same exact way as countries
just on a small scale neighborhoods
surrounded by walls and fences to
protect citizens from other citizens and
the only difference is it's by choice
but the physical and mental effects on
the people living inside and the people
kept outside are the same
separating cities neighborhoods and even
playgrounds in the spring of last year I
worked on a design project in Brussels
at two elementary schools but this was
the case both the schools share an
entrance and a school yard both schools
teach in Dutch but one school is mainly
visited by Belgian children and the
other school by immigrant children the
schools are separated by walls and
fences leaving the children no point of
interaction other than this fence on the
schoolyard that separates them when I
started to work there it made me sad to
see children having to stand at a fence
to talk to their friend on the other
side but what's even worse is that most
of the children will never get the
opportunity to even make a friend on the
other side school should be the place
for children all children come together
and learn learn from the teacher but
more importantly learn from each other
and the more diversity the more there is
to learn
in fact school might be the only time in
our lives for establishing a contact
despite social differences is even
possible separating children during this
time of their development will make
integration extremely difficult if not
impossible and yet somehow I seem to be
the only one having a problem with this
fence in Brussels most of the parents
teachers and children stopped seeing or
at least questioning the structure it's
just how it is nobody has ever seen it
differently and people are in favor of
it I once asked the boy if he would like
to play with the other side and he said
no then I asked if he would play with
them if the fence wasn't there and he
that probably but then he quickly added
that the fence should stay because the
other side is mean and they never give
back his ball it's funny because I
talked to children from both sides and
everyone told me that the other side is
mean because they never give back it's a
ball the children on both sides dislike
each other and there are regularly
arguments breaking out at this fence
which is also the main reason why people
feel the need for it to be there it
protects the children from each other
or at least the toys and it prevents
chaos at some point the children started
to crawl beneath the fence to get their
ball back and the reaction of the
schools was to put these metal plates
there now they climb over I don't know
what came first in Brussels a mental
wall that grew too strong it made them
build a physical sense or this fence
that now emphasizes the social
differences even on the schoolyard but
what I did know when I started to work
there was that I wanted to change
something about the situation I wanted
to show both sides again how much they
have in common for children this isn't
very hard because even though one
schoolyard speaks Dutch and the other
schoolyard a mix of French Turkish and
Arabic they all speak the universal
language of play and it turned out the
desire to play is a lot stronger than
all the supposed differences between
them
I installed different games at the fence
which turned it into an interface a
common ground instead of a barrier and
all of a sudden children were drawing
together exchanging pencils and talking
on the phone especially the phones were
great success because they were so
amazed by the fact that they can hear
the other side through this device that
they couldn't stop speaking in the case
of an elementary school parents play a
very big role in shaping the everyday
life and the environment of their
children so I knew that if I wanted to
make a difference I had to somehow show
them to how much they have in common
with the other side but for parents this
was a lot more difficult because most of
them speak different languages work
different jobs with different income
live in different social circles believe
in different
experience different cultures and share
different values and then it was me a
student different in all of these
aspects again so how could I show them
how much they have in common I chose not
to convince them myself
but by letting their own children do the
talking I designed a picture exhibition
on the schoolyard showing them their
children playing together through the
fence at the end of this exhibition I
asked people to write down thoughts
ideas and wishes on these big wooden
boxes and I labeled the boxes with what
do you think a lot of people wrote yes
on it yes what I never mentioned my
opinion or an action that should follow
so which question were they answering
with yes when I asked they said yes the
fence should go yes we want to play with
the other side the pictures implied
enough to answer a question that was
never proposed people were seeing the
absurdity of the situation again and
felt how unnecessary this fence is
without me forcing an opinion on them
the exhibition showed the two sides
their similarities for once that day
there was no us and them there was no
others the mental wall started to
crumble I chose the word crumbling
because breaking a mental wall is a long
journey and breaking a mental wall can
be a lot more difficult than simply
tearing down the physical one we have to
challenge our opinion and beliefs and
maybe even admit our own wrongs so what
happened in Brussels was a big step a
step that has been taking generations in
Germany there are many examples from all
over the world telling the same story I
experienced in Brussels and Germany
enough examples from which we could have
learned but still we seek walls as
solutions for problems that they cannot
solve because walls don't fight the root
of our problem if anything they reduce
the symptoms so the next time you are
planning to build a wall
or you are planning to support someone
who wants to build a wall I want you to
remember the impact you are really
having because this simple structure
will hardly create more security instead
it will affect the people living with it
every day people who despite the
geographic border often share a lot of
culture and values for them you are not
building one wall but to two vaults
which will take decades and generations
to overcome again